your doctor may recommend dialysis
a procedure that removes
waste products from your blood
if your kidneys are not
working properly
healthy kidneys filter waste,
extra fluid and electrolytes such
as sodium and potassium
from the  blood these waste products pass
out of the body through the
urethra as urine when you have
kidney disease the kidneys
gradually stop working, leading to
a buildup of harmful waste and
extra fluid in your body
increased blood pressure and
bone or blood problems
and dialysis may also be
done to treat acute kidney failure
which occurs when your kidneys
suddenly stop working or
to remove drugs or
toxic substances from your body
in a type of dialysis called
hemodialysis
The doctor will use a machine called a
dialyzer
to clean the blood out of your
body
some  a few weeks or months before
starting hemodialysis
your doctor will prepare a vascular access site
in your body
your doctor will create either an
arteriovenous graft or an
arteriovenous fistula to access your bloodstream
to start the area will be numbed with
a local anesthetic to place a
arteriovenous graft the surgeon will make a
small incision in your forearm and
insert a soft plastic tube
called a graft to connect an
artery to a vein
to create an arteriovenous fistula the
surgeon will make a small incision in your
skin and connect an artery to a
vein to make an arteriovenous fistula  larger blood vessel
called a fistula
once your vascular access site
has healed your doctor may start
hemodialysis to begin your
dialysis nurse will insert two needles into your
fistula ave or graft
once the circuit is established
your blood will slowly flow out of  his
body and through the maker inside
the slider his blood  you will find
fibers for filtering and an
absorbent cleaning solution called
dialysis fluid
the fibers will remove waste and
excess fluid as well as
electrolytes from your blood
the clean blood will leave the maker and
enter your body through the tube
through  the second needle from your
access site
when your
hemodialysis session is finished the needles
and tubing will be removed and you can go home
on another type of dialysis called the
peritoneum the membranes that line your
abdomen are used to clean
blood without removing it from your body
Before starting peritoneal dialysis,
you will have an operation to
implant a flexible tube called a
catheter.
The surgeon will insert the catheter near your
navel, creating a port that will
allow fluid to flow in and out of
your abdomen. Each
peritoneal dialysis session is called
exchange first you will
use your catheter to fill your
abdomen with slip fluid  for a
period of time determined by your
doctor through the peritoneal membrane
waste products and excess
fluid are continuously removed from your
blood into alicante
fluid alicante fluid laden with
waste materials is removed from your
abdomen  to be deposited in a
disposable collection bag during your
exchange